climbing up frozen waterfalls isn't for
everyone but a recent lack of decent
snow for skiers and frequent cold
temperatures at lower levels has seen a
dramatic increase in people taking up
this sport people were trying to find
other activities to do and ice climbing
is fantastic but a lot of people are
scared of it
so maybe this year because they are no
choice they decided to try to give it a
go and it was a success according to a
recent survey of its members the British
mountain guides Association say it's now
a crucial part of their work an extra
staff had been flown out to the Alps to
teach ice climbing because of demand so
we're here in libera in France close to
the Swiss border and we've come here
because guides say this is an
increasingly popular place for ice
climbing it's early in the morning and
there's already a lot of people
gathering here but this ice wall has
been artificially boosted locals have
diverted water from the nearby stream to
help match demand and contribute to this
ice full I'm going to do a lot more
winter climbing in Scotland this season
but I realized that here conditions were
actually quite good for getting into it
at the start of the season and the
clients can be quite long and daunting
in Scotland and I realized that here
it's a lot easier to get into some of
these short kind of single pictures of
your people that are new to it the views
from high up may be impressive but it
can be potentially very dangerous for
example falling ice Avalanche threats
and the ice itself can be unstable if
there's a big temperature change whilst
the sport has helped businesses keep
busy it's not a natural alternative to
skiing dude has some excellent skiing
but then we had a high front come in and
we've had I think
five weeks of just sunshine and cold
weather there has been an impact
definitely but now that it started
snowing I think that things will pick up
very quickly so went up to concern the
high pressure has also seen paragliding
unseasonable thrive with sales up 80% in
the shamon e valley so whilst the
weather has presented challenging
conditions for some winter sports it has
given others the chance to take off
Angela Barnes Sky News in the French
Alps